quand il s'agit d'une mission de vol spatial,
je pense que tous ceux qui
veulent vraiment faire cela devraient vouloir faire
partie de la toute prochaine mission
oh
donc nous ne volerons pas d'équipage, nous
volerons vers des mannequins et des torses
qui  sont des tissus et
des organes humains simulés qui examinent la
radioprotection l'environnement de rayonnement l'
accélération du véhicule et comment
cela affecte le corps humain parce que notre
objectif est aussi le vol brut sur artemis
je travaille depuis sept ans maintenant sur
artemis un bras  programme et c'est
parfois facile de perdre de vue le
fait que
vous volez, vous construisez et
concevez un vaisseau spatial qui va aller
sur la lune qui est prêt à transporter des
humains et puis de temps en temps je
m'arrête en quelque sorte et  j'ai réalisé wow
c'est ce que je
vais réellement faire
canapé en
le regardant aux actualités ou si je suis au
contrôle de mission en train de parler à l'équipage, vous
devez aller sur la lune, tous ceux-là
vont se sentir bien
et donc quel que soit votre rôle, vous devriez
l'embrasser mais nous devrions tous  Je veux
être sur la prochaine chose qui fume
on mène
à artemis deux qui mène à artemis
trois quand on espère avoir des humains à la
surface de la lune mais artemis iii
mène au reste du programme artemis
la première femme la première personne de
couleur à la surface de la lune et ensuite
les premiers humains à se rendre sur
mars et à mettre nos pas dans
la construction de laboratoires scientifiques et à
habiter une autre
autre planète